all right our series a more perfect
union aims to show what unites us as
Americans is stronger than what divides
us we reported earlier that President
Trump plans to declare a public health
emergency over the opioid epidemic for
women in West Virginia already have made
it their first priority they live in the
state with the highest overdose rate in
the country Michelle Miller traveled to
Martinsburg West Virginia to meet the
hope dealers you can find it at all
hours whether it's late at night whether
it's you know in the in the middle of
the afternoon Christie Plattner knows
all the trouble spots in Martinsburg
West Virginia the worst part that you're
gonna see it is Winchester Avenue that's
where a lot of activity goes on from the
7-eleven all the way out to the motels
this was once a textile town but the
factories have long since closed many
people here have filled the empty spaces
in their lives with opioids it's a city
in desperate need of a hero who's lost
someone to heroin it got four of them
heroines actually as ironic as that
sounds I lost my son-in-law a week
before Christmas 2015 and I lost my
daughter and they Lisa Meltzer Tina
stride Tara Mason and Kristy plot nur
are four women all affected by the
heroin plague I have a son that is
actually one year clean from heroin Tara
I was in a relationship that was touched
with drug use how bad was it six years I
have a daughter who also got hooked due
to a prescription medication after a
broken arm so all four of you know it
can happen to anybody
absolutely they called themselves hope
dealers the four women came together at
a meeting seeking support among other
families harmed by addiction you kind of
glanced over at one the other ones
sobbing and crying I'm sobbing and
crying and we disconnected instead of
dealing dope in our community let's
steal some hope so that's how we became
the hope dealer project she is going to
ask Valley to help her get into the
rehab we call the detox centers we
secure a bed if they have one and at
that point usually Tina and Christy or
the hospital with them which they have
to sit there for anywhere from two to
seven hours and how long are those
commute closest one is two and a half
hours away furthest one is six and a
half hours so you're the hand holders at
times
sometimes the butt-kickers yeah one of
the butts they kicked belong to Tiffany
arredondo what his heroin cost you
everything that I had my family my home
cars that I had my kids I lost all the
rights to my kids Arredondo is a
recovering heroin addict she grew up
here by her estimate she's lost 22
people to heroin since high school
including a cousin and two sisters who's
helped you Tina the hope dealers the
sundae that I wanted to get help January
7th they actually chased me down the
whole day went to my dealers house like
yeah they found fearless oh yeah she's
been clean for ten months now so how
long before this came along Peter
Callahan is an addiction counselor in
Martinsburg he says the hope dealers
have tripled the number of people
getting access to treatment 16 beds what
kind of a difference can that make it's
a small drop and he credits them with
applying pressure to the state to help
fund a new detox facility in their city
so with the hope dealer springs is to
the table is here's an option for
treatment here's an option for you to
make a choice to get help and they're
taking it Christy where does that
commitment come from it comes from
knowing that someone needs help knowing
that a mother can go to sleep that night
knowing her kid is on the way to a detox
center they're not laying in bed
wondering where is my child so she told
me on the way up there I can't even
believe I'm alive for women dealing hope
in a town where hope is hard to find for
CBS this morning Michelle Miller
Martinsburg West Virginia and we should
let you know that the hope dealers
received recognition in WV living
magazine's wonder women edition that
honor is important because their work is
all volunteer they rely on fundraising
and donations and kudos and once again a
reminder these are people who are
seeking so
they are solution-focused just their
whole philosophy though of dealing hope
and not dope I hope people are getting
out their checkbooks now because you can
see that's money well spent
absolutely very much so local initiative
that's right well done